- You know, I can't end the show
without giving you one last gift of joy
this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Two weeks ago we lost the
legendary Betty White.
This coming Monday would
be Betty's 100th birthday
and a new documentary
of her amazing career
will debut in theaters that day.
Take a look.
- Hello, I'm Betty White.
- You're invited to experience
the amazing life of Betty
White on January 17th.
- Betty White.
- Betty White, ladies and gentlemen.
- Dorothy, was Sophia naked just now
or does her dress really need ironing?
(laughing)
- Love her.
The documentary was in the works
long before Betty's passing,
but it contains her last time on camera
recorded just 11 days
before the world lost her.
Joining us as the producer
and director of the film,
Steve Boettcher.
Hi Steve.
- Hey Kelly,
how are you?
- I'm so good.
I'm so sad we're talking
under these circumstances,
but I'm so glad at least y'all
were working on this project
and we have this like last little gift.
All of America is devastated
by Betty's passing,
so what do you hope people take
away from your documentary?
- You know, we've been
working on this project
for about 10 years
and I didn't really realize
this was gonna be like
a love letter to Betty,
but I think at the end,
that's what this is.
It's a love letter to
Betty and her fans and
you know, it radiates her
heart and her happiness
and her humor and it's pure Betty White.
- I love that.
So you worked closely with
Betty on this project.
So what did you come
to appreciate about her
that maybe we don't know?
- You know, it's that
razor sharp sense of humor,
that's Betty that I just,
you can't help, but love.
She always would say,
I be traveling with her,
we'd be arm and arm.
and she'd said, oh, by the
way, Steve Boettcher's with me,
he's been embedded with
me for the last 10 years.
And she would wink when
she said it embedded with.
(laughing)
And it was just kind of like, you know,
I was always part of the
joke, you know what I mean?
But by nature, she's a troublemaker,
her sense of humor is a troublemaker,
but I think it defines her
and you know, just kind of a rascal
and that's what I love about her.
- I mean, yeah.
What a life.
Betty White: A Celebration
is in theaters nationwide
and only for one day,
Monday, January 17th.
For ticket information,
go to our shows Insta story right now.
Thank you so much, Steve.
This is such a blessing to all of us
to be able to lift her up
- Thank you, Kelly.
- and enjoy her.
I'm liking your post right now.
- Thank you so much.
- All right well, usually
this is the part of the show.
When we give our guests a thousand dollars
on behalf of our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of FriXion
the go to erasable pen
at the Kelly Clarkson Show,
but today in honor of Betty White,
who was a lifelong advocate for animals,
we're donating the thousand dollars
to Wagmor Pets Dog Rescue
and we'd like to encourage
all of you to donate
to your local animal shelters
in Betty's honor as well.